how many times do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
no one no one cares how many times you
fell off the bicycle if you ride the
bicycle now sometimes we look for
evidence in our life and it hasn't
happened and I think it's so important
we still show up that's where you're
changing the most and when you get to
that point where you could care less
you're changing the signal in the field
then if you're able to maintain that
state for an extended period of time I
say something magical is going to happen
happen in your life something unusual
some unknown experience is going to
occur when a person can create the right
type of energy the right type of
frequency from the field and there's a
vibrational match between their energy
and whatever they want in their life all
of a sudden they start drawing
experiences to them out of nowhere it's
so much easier to forget that Vision
than to remember it so if you're going
to remember it you got to keep it alive
in your mind don't be thinking about
what's going to happen in your day you
already know what's going to happen
don't think what happened yesterday you
already know that get in the present
moment moment and say who do I want to
be when I open my eyes hey it's EV
Carmichael and I watch these videos
every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goals kickstarting your day with a
blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
# believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you if you keep thinking the same
thoughts if you keep making the same
choices you keep doing the same things
you keep creating the same experiences
you keep feeling the same emotions I
don't know let's be
conservative you do that for 10
years you would have to agree with me
then that it would become more automatic
it be become more
unconscious so your personality creates
your personal reality that's it that is
it and your personality is made of how
you think how you act and how you
feel so keep thinking the same way keep
acting the same way keep feeling the
same way your personality is the same
and your personality personal reality
would be the same as well so if you
wanted to change your life if you wanted
to change your personal reality you
would have to change your
personality and then you'd have to start
thinking about what you've been thinking
about and decide if you really want to
believe that any
longer and when does the story
end it's it's that moment that you
become so conscious of that thought
you're so tired of it you're so aware of
it that you would never let it slip by
your awareness ever
again you catch yourself complaining and
blaming and making excuses and feeling
sorry for yourself and that's been your
unconscious program then the moment you
become conscious of those unconscious
behaviors you're out of the program
you're only in the program when you're
unconscious and so it takes an enormous
amount of energy and awareness to
separate from those programs and then
there's those emotions that we feel
every single day that are so familiar to
us that we don't even know what they are
we just feel guilty we don't even know
it's guilt it's just how we
feel and the stronger the emotions that
we have to experiences in our life the
more altered we are inside of us when
the chemistry changes inside of the
brain Narrows the focus on the cause and
takes a snapshot or a series of
snapshots and that's called a long-term
memory and so then makes total sense
then that a person by every time they
relive that event in their life they're
making the same chemistry in their brain
and and their body and their body is
literally believing it's living that
experience over and over
again and now the body's so in the past
that it's the mind of the
past so
then the act of becoming so conscious
that you don't go unconscious is a
changing of
Consciousness how many times do we have
to
forget until we stop forgetting and
start remembering that is the moment of
change rule number two is Master your
emotions if you're living in stress and
you're living in survival and that
system is switched on then everything
will be a threat everything will be a
danger everything will be a reason to
rush to be in to be frustrated to be
judgmental because that's that's the
Consciousness that's the emotion we're
living by so now you you have a a
problem with a coworker you have a
problem with your partner whatever it is
that you use as an example and you have
to give a presentation now now you
really have one of two choices you be
victimized by those conditions in your
life and you stay in that emotional
state and I'll say to you Jay why are
you that way well I'm this way because
of this person the circumstance the
person or circumstance is controlling
the way I feel and the way I think
anything that controls the way I feel
and the way I think I'm victim to right
okay or I actually can be a Creator now
okay so when it's the hardest it matters
the most okay so there's going to be a
story a valid story that's going to go
along with those emotions that you're
going to have to give up that you can
address at another time from a different
state if you're altered in that state
and you say something you do something
you write the email you send the text
you'll always regret it you'll say I
should have never said that I should
have never done that we got to learn
that we're in an altered state at that
time so there's only one of two choices
you either stay there the whole day and
tell everybody that story or you say
okay let me take a moment remember that
this is the experiment called life okay
let me practice getting relaxed to my
heart let me slow the animal down let me
practice that take a few minutes now let
me breathe let me get my state back let
me change everything okay let me
remember who I am who I want to be when
I open my eyes and me practice that
again now even if you had to do that 10
times in one day I would say it was a
day worth living I would say it was a
day worth living and when we do walking
meditations uh in our our Retreats we're
doing walking meditations so you can
practice doing it with your eyes open
like if you're going to be relaxed in
your heart and awake in your brain and
you can do it with your eyes closed okay
let's take it out for a test drive yeah
let me open my eyes let me pay a little
bit more attention to my inner World let
me practice feeling this feeling let me
practice feeling this way and let my
brain do what it does let me get defined
let me change my physiology let me
change my state let me walk as the
healed person let me walk as the
Abundant person let me walk as if my
prayers are answered let me walk in the
state if I keep practicing that over and
over it's going to become a habit right
yeah so so we hit it as many ways as we
can we have at least seven or eight
different breaths that we do because we
see how they all work in the
brain we have all kinds of meditations
we have sitting meditations you have
standing and walking meditations we have
laying down meditations because we want
you to be able to do it with your eyes
open with your eyes closed standing
walking any way you can so that you
don't default and return back to that
person now if you do default you didn't
fail that's a program you just went
unconscious and how many times do we
have to forget until we stop forgetting
and start remembering that's the moment
of change no one no one cares how many
times you fell off the bicycle if you
ride the bicycle now you ride the
so it's it's the constant process uh
every single day and I think that
sometimes we look for evidence in our
life and it hasn't happened and I think
it's so important that we still show up
yeah yeah cuz that's the that's where
you're changing the most and when you
get to that point where you could care
less if it happens or not because you
feel so happy so grateful for who you
are get ready because your life is going
to begin to change in magical ways rule
number three is create synchronicities
when a person can create the right type
of energy the right type of frequency
from the field and there's a vibrational
match between their energy and whatever
they want in their life all of a sudden
they start drawing experiences to them
out of nowhere they get the phone call
hey I got synic as synchronicity why
because you're synchronizing your
energy to a possibility in your life now
in the want
them every thought has a
frequency so when a person has the
thought of their new job and they can
feel the frequency of that thought it
wouldn't be lack it wouldn't be
separation it wouldn't be frustration
the frequency of the thought of a new
job would create the feeling of euphoria
excitement Bliss
gratitude and thoughts tend to be
Electric in the quantum field and
feelings tend to be magnetic and now we
teach people how to create a Wi-Fi
signal when when they connect to the
field and they literally change their
energy the thought being the electrical
charge the feeling being the magnetic
charge and how you think and how you
feel is broadcasting energy
now there's a little bit more that has
to happen because you have to have
coherence in your brain the brain's got
to be very orderly and it's emitting a
field and the heart which it can do with
stress stress stress is static stress
you disconnect because all of your
attention is going on everything
physical and material and you're drawing
from this energy that's surrounding your
body and you're turning into chemistry
and now you're isolated you're separate
so we teach people how to get that brain
coherence going and the Heart coherence
is going and coherence is rhythm and
Order and now you have this wi-fi signal
and when there's a vibrational match
you've synchronized your energy to
synchronicity those serendipities those
coincidences those uh synchronicities
those opportunities start coming to
you now what's the cool part about that
it seems like there's a shortening of
time between the thought of what you
want and the experience of what you want
between cause and effect when we create
from the field instead of from matter if
we get really good at it then the
feedback that we experience in our life
is letting us know that we're doing
something correctly and when you start
getting the phone call or the email or
the introduction to somebody and you
scratch your head and you go oh my God
I'm the creator of my life and all of a
sudden the next day your
belief in what's
possible grows dramatically so when you
sit down to do it the next time you get
better at it and all of a sudden more
synchronicities start to happen and so
the side effect of it is uh and this is
what I'm proud of in our community is
that people do the work they don't they
don't do it because they have to
do they do it because they don't want
the magic to end they want it they want
the synchronicities to be happening now
number four is believe in yourself if
you believe in yourself it means you
have to believe in possibility and if
you believe in possibility you're going
to have to believe in yourself and so
something really cool happens when you
do this that just discovered recently
just watching people at our week-long
events um you know cuz you got to go all
in you got to go all in and it's 7 days
and it's a lot and it's super intense
and there's times where you don't want
to show up because I'm pushing people
across the river of change there comes a
moment where people keep showing up for
themselves they keep showing up for
themselves in spite of the weather in
spite of their footo hurting in spite of
their bad dream in spite of whatever
their fight with or whoever they keep
showing going up they get really worthy
to receive they is no they feel really
worthy like I am worthy to receive this
gift and the universe only gives us what
we think we're worthy of receiving right
so we got to get to that point because
so many people who are in
lack somehow don't feel worthy right so
so the abundance
then becomes the sign that you finally
become worthy and for the soul it's not
about the abundance it's about mastering
your worthiness and the reflection is
the things that you accumulate listen my
dad used to say this to me all the time
he'd say wait wait wait wait wait a
second wait a second just sit down with
me here if anybody else can do it you
could do it also also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is stay present I
would love for you to share the mission
that you're on and how people can break
past the memory of who they've been so
they can tap into the potential of who
they can be well a habit is a redundant
set of automatic unconscious thoughts
behaviors and emotions that's acquired
through repetition habit is when you've
done something so many times that your
body actually knows how to do it better
than your conscious mind it's a habit so
people wake up in the morning and they
run through the same routine every
single day
and the routine is mapped out
neurologically in their brain if they
have the thought of the coffee maker
they make the choice to go over there
they do the thing to make the coffee
they have the experience of drinking it
they feel the emotion associated with it
that becomes a pattern it becomes more
automatic it becomes second nature so we
have a series of these redundant
patterns then and in time we lose our
free
will to a set of programs and the body
is programmed into the predictable
future based on what we've done in the
past and that's how we lose the free
will to a set of
programs so that habituation is the
predictable future and that's the
known and other people wake up in the
morning and they romance their memories
of the past they they think about the
problems that they have in their lives
and those problems are connected to
certain people and certain objects and
certain things at certain times and
places and since the brain is a record
of the past the moment they remember
that problem they're thinking in the
past and every one of those problems has
an emotion that's associated with
it so the moment the person feels
unhappy the moment the person feels fear
the moment the person feels unworthy the
moment the person feels sad now the
body's in the past because thoughts are
the language of the brain and feelings
of the language of the body and how we
think and how we feel creates our state
of being and so it's that thought and
that feeling it's that image or that
memory and the emotion it's that
stimulus and
response that's conditioning the body to
become mind of that emotion and now the
body is so
objective that it does not know the
difference between the real life
experience that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that that person is
creating by thought alone and the body
is reliving the same past experience
over and over again and if we can't
think greater than how we feel or
feelings have become the means of
thinking than we're thinking in the past
and if we believe that our thoughts have
anything to do with our destiny then our
future is going to look a lot like our
past so that familiar past also is the
known and so what we discovered is that
if you could teach a
person to when their bodies sitting in a
meditation as an
example and it's off schedule it's used
to feeling angry at 8:00 in the morning
because it watches the
news the person experiences traffic
every day they get 11:00 they check
their
emails and they start judging other
people you know there's a there's a set
of familiar emotions that person has
been living by we discovered that if a
person can sit
past that memory that they can sit past
that emotion that causes them to get
aroused to get frustrated to get
impatient that's the emotion that causes
the person to quit and they have this
conclusion that they can't meditate or
they can't focus or they have ADD it's a
story they tell themselves about the
past we discovered though that when a
person sits past those those thoughts
that say I can't it's too hard I'll
never change I need a brain scan there's
something wrong with me it's my mother's
fault and they're curious to see what's
on the other side of that thought when
their body gets aroused and frustrated
instead of giving up and saying um I
have too many things to do that they
actually learn a way to settle the body
back down into the present moment and
it's David versus Goliath and every time
we can become conscious that we get
emotional we get frustrated get
impatient and we settle the body down
we're executing a
will now that's greater than the program
and the body is no longer the mind the
person is now be becoming conscious of
their unconscious self and it takes an
enormous amount of
energy it takes an enormous amount of
awareness to stay present because to
stay present is to be in the unknown
that's when you can't predict the future
and that's not when you're remembering
the past and the unknown in the program
that we have as biological creatures is
a scary place is it's better to run from
the unknown than to hang out in it rule
number six is practice meditation we
teach meditation three ways to become
familiar with your old self and to
become familiar with your new self
that's what the word meditation means
familiarization to become familiar with
so we use that model for change so slow
your brain waves down and get beyond
your analytical mind is meditation and
you teach your body how to do that and
we've discovered a formula that that
simply makes it very easy for people to
do it you practice it you'll get good at
it just like anything else you practice
so so to get beyond the analytical mind
there's another way to reprogram
ourselves and then meditation is really
about getting beyond your body or
disconnecting from your body
disconnecting from your environment and
forgetting about time and that is that
eye of the needle where we begin to make
the most significant changes so we're
data driven you know we're we're really
looking to see what it is and and when
we see uh brains respond in the same way
it helps me enormously to teach the
material better and so the more people
understand what they're doing and the
more they understand why they're doing
it the more naturally the how becomes
easier and nothing is left to conjecture
if nothing is left to Superstition or
Dogma or even in
spiritual you know traditional words you
science says the Contemporary language
to demystify that process you you give
new people numerous times to overcome
themselves and numerous times to connect
sooner or later you'll start watching
transformation right before your eyes
and so one of the cool things that we've
discovered is that we have so much
compelling data to suggest that you're
greater than you think more powerful
than you no more unlimited than you
could ever dream we have compelling data
that suggest that your nervous system is
the greatest pharmacist in the world
that it makes drugs that work better
than any drug in a drug store a drug
study is about 18 to 25% cause and
effect causality our data is between 75
in 85% cause and effect this is a person
creating their own Pharmacy of
anti-inflammatories their own Pharmacy
of anti-carcinogenic chemicals their own
Pharmacy of uh pain relievers we're
seeing this over and over again so we
have this incredible data that says that
this is no longer pseudoscience this is
the real this is really science the side
effect of a person's
transformation is has changed my belief
in what's possible I have seen people
stand on the stage with stage four
cancers that were in every single organ
in their body that metastasize and and
they have no sign of cancer in their
body and we have data that suggests that
you put the blood of an advanced
meditator and a uterine cancer cell a
pancreatic cancer
cell 70% of the mitochondrial function
in the cancer cell is diminished the
mitochondria is the energy packets of
the cell it's taking energy out of the
cancer cell works perfect with what
we're seeing with uh uh the testimonials
uh that that people are telling around
the world we've seen blind people see
we've seen death people here we've seen
uh people with spinal cord injuries walk
again we've seen U ALS change we've seen
all kinds of unbelievable health
conditions change by a person simply
changing the way they think the way they
act and the way they feel rule number
seven is serve others I'm interested in
unifying as many many different branches
of science in a very simplistic
way that I give people tools that they
have within their reach to prove to
themselves that they're greater than
they think more powerful than they know
more unlimited than they could ever
dream all I offer people is my greatest
understanding of the
truth and numerous opportunities to
experience it nothing more I want to
free their
minds and open their hearts with a
simple formula leads them to a door a
door of unlimited possibilities and I've
come to learn that I can only show them
the door uh they're the ones that have
to walk through it I never thought
coherence would be anything that I would
be studying right I mean I never thought
that at
all but when I started really looking at
the physics behind coherence
you know there is an invisible field of
energy that we are sitting in right now
that that we are unaware of and if we're
unaware of it it doesn't exist for
us we experience separation because of
that the more we become aware of that
invisible
field the more we're not our bodies the
more we're not aware of our environment
the more we are less aware of
time there's a door that we can pass
through to the quantum field is pure
Consciousness rule number eight is have
a vision wake up every day how bad do
you want it how bad do you want your
dream it's so much easier to forget that
Vision than to remember it right so if
you're going to remember you got to keep
it alive in your mind how do you keep it
alive in your mind you you disconnect
from your environment you close your
eyes you play music in the background
you get sit your body down and it's got
to pee and it's got to eat and it's got
to you just just sit down for a few
minutes like training a dog like stay
when I say it's time to get up we get up
don't be thinking about what's going to
happen in your day you already know it's
going to happen don't think would
happened yesterday you already know that
get in the present moment and say who do
I want to be when I open my eyes who do
I want to be today what would greatness
look like how how would I how would one
day one shot one life time what would an
abundant person do let me rehearse that
with my eyes closed let me remind myself
who I don't want to be let me remind
myself who do I want to be let's not get
up Lewis until we get into that until we
are till we the tennis ball hits The
Sweet Spot when you go oh I'm ready for
the day now now game on now if you can
maintain that modified State of Mind and
Body the entire day without defaulting
by seeing someone or doing something
stay in that state the experiment still
continues and you're changing your
energy doesn't happen in 2 days days
you're not that good right that's it
you're not that good we keep
practicing people who show up the for
the 21 weeks in a row this woman 21
weeks in a row the end of 21 weeks she
knew it boom her whole life changed boom
was the 21 days worth to ask her the
experiment she was just changing the
process rule number nine is develop good
breathing habits if you could learn how
to rest your attention in your heart and
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy
regulate your breath start slowing your
breathing down even if you did it for
one minute you could actually begin to
change your brain waves MH and you could
actually cause your heart to start
functioning more regulation and more or
order if you said okay I'm going to work
with my body and I'm going to start
breathing and I'm going to start feeling
emotions that I do want to feel yes it
may take you a few minutes to get there
but if you keep practicing it over and
over again the heart starts producing a
very profound signal it starts to
produce an external magnetic field it's
it's it's
measurable so now you have a coherent
brain which means you can get very
intentional and you have a coherent
heart which means you can feel the
emotions of your future before it
happens somehow you have this
broadcasting of this wi-fi signal uh and
the Brain tends to be electrical in
nature so it's sends out an electrical
charge into the field the heart is the
magnetic charge it's what draws things
to us it's the it's the magnetic field
and now you actually by changing the way
you think and the way you feel you're
changing the signal in the field and if
you're able to maintain that state for
an extended period of time I say
something magical is going to happen in
your life something unusual some unknown
experience is going to occur if you keep
thinking the same way and feeling the
same way your life should stay the same
and number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is sync your
heart with your brain I would love for
you to speak into how when we find
coherence when we find alignment between
brain and heart then we can we can
Steward whatever reality we want to us
in in record time yeah so one of the
things that we we do is we we when
you're agitated at someone and on a zoom
call and you know you're doing
the and you're thinking about five ways
to throttle them you know I'm joking but
you get the idea you're aroused by
something that knocks you out of balance
and you're sitting there you know your
heart's beating against the closed
system it's pumping blood but you're not
running you're not fighting you're not
hiding and it starts it starts creating
problems the heart starts beating out of
order out of
rhythm and so we discovered when we
started seeing teaching
people how to place their attention on
their heart when they where you place
your attention is where you place your
and out of all the things that you feel
with you know what I'm talking about
with your body we ask people to feel
with nothing but their heart and where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy and we we started
seeing we started hooking up the heart
the the ECG monitors with the brain and
every time the heart would flux into
coherence you would see this wave of
alpha just this beautiful coherent wave
of alpha heart was telling the brain
create and Alpha is a creative state and
when we're in Alpha we see in pictures
we see in images we're imagining when
we're in beta we're thinking we're
analyzing that's the voice in your head
so we saw that when the person dropped
into their heart really well there was
this kind of wave of information that
that went to the brain and caused the
brain to become very coherent and it was
always after the heart uh doing was in
that state and so we started realizing
that the heart was the creative Center
it was it's it's when we move out of
these first three centers and we move
into our heart when we move into that
Center The Heart starts telling the
brain starts informing the brain so we
started building instruments with in
with our brain scientists and our and
our scientific team where we could
actually see how this kind of phenoma
worked and so when a person starts
putting their attention in their heart
we start seeing this
uh low frequency this very low frequency
in the heart that's only indigenous to
the heart start to fill up like a gas
tank just the person's just putting
their attention on their heart and
they're giving their heart the energy it
needs to beat that's what that frequency
is about so you're feeding it an energy
so we see it kind of go up like a gas
tank and then we see the parasympathetic
nervous SYM come up with it and what
does that mean the person's relaxing
right so now they're relaxing but then
all of a sudden we see the the
parasympathetic nervous system about to
drop down and here comes the sympathetic
nervous system and now the person's
having a little
arousal and we started discovering that
when this occurs when a person is
relaxed in their heart there's energy
that moves to the brain the person
starts seeing possibilities that they
they never saw before and so getting
really good at relaxing in your heart
and Awakening your brain causes this
kind of synchronization that takes Place
between the two they're they're dancing
together in this really beautiful way
and when they're uh in the same or
similar frequency uh if you're sharing
the same frequency you're sharing the
same information now the brain may think
but the heart knows and I'm telling you
it is a straight shooter it does not
beat around the bush at all and now the
heart starts telling informing the brain
giving it the information that the
person needs for themselves in their
lives
we can do this we take people that we
can train them to do this and they can
do it in 15 minutes and when when they
start getting really good at relaxing
more in their heart and more energy
begins to move into their brain we start
seeing this very crazy thing happen in
the brain where delta waves are now
carrying theta waves and theta waves are
carrying alpha waves and alpha waves are
carrying beta waves and beta waves are
carrying High beta waves and high beta
waves carrying gamma waves in a whole
entire brain
is functioning in resonance there're
patterns within patterns within patterns
within patterns that person is having a
very profound uh transcendental moment
so we work with getting really relaxed
in our hearts and awake in our brain we
do it so much I want people to get so
good at doing it with their eyes
closed they can do it with their eyes
open because relaxing the heart and a
wake in the brain is so much better than
stressed out unconscious and living in a
program
there's tiny little calcium carbonate
crystals in the pineal gland that are
stacked on top of each other in the
human being
rhombohedrons and they're stacked up on
top of each other and the research
says that it has Paso Electric
properties what does that mean I looked
it
up when you apply a mechanical
stress to these crystals the mechanical
stress begins to create an electrical
charge in the
Crystal and the compression begins to
polarize the ends of the crystal with a
positive charge and a negative charge
and when you polarize the crystal with a
what do you have a
magnet and all of a sudden as you
compress those crystals the mechanical
stress creates an electrical
field and that field actually expands
until the crystals can't stretch any
longer and then the field
reverses and when the field reverses the
field actually exerts a pressure against
the crystals
again that causes the crystals to expand
and the next thing you know you have a
little radio
receiver how many people
understand and you switch on the brains
radio receiver and now the brain can
tune in the
frequencies beyond the
senses and that is the mystical gland
and the research says it's a transducer
how do I know I looked it up I didn't go
on social I looked it up transducer like
a television antenna that's what it
said taking energy and information in
one form and turning it into pictures
and images
meaning and that's why it's called the
third eye because you have an inner
Vision that's more real than the outer
world the brain now is picking up
information from the field and it's
transducing it into profound imagery a
mystical transcendental moment and we do
the breath when you finish that breath
I'm going to ask you to finish it right
on that pineal Glam that's your Target
and I'm going to ask you to hold your
breath now this is not
torture I'm not asking you to hold your
breath to see how long you can hold your
breath if you're thinking about how long
you're holding your breath you're not
doing it I want your attention as you
hold your breath I'm going to ask you to
lift this up pull this in lock this down
straighten your spine drop down and pump
and squeeze a little bit more and I just
want you to keep squeezing and pushing
that fluid right up against that Target
there
and I'll say exhale and then you feel
and we go get it
again I don't feel like it is not going
to do anything I'm too old nothing will
happen you got to leave that behind you
you got to get lost in the
act and when that energy moves I have
had it
happen thousands of times it is
big it's not like ooh I'm an energy
worker it's not like that it's like holy
heck it's a train that's moving and it
goes right up to the
brain and that energy is being released
in the brain and the Brain goes into
those gamma brainwave patterns very high
gamma brain wave patterns can you share
that you used to be concerned about
folks who would criticize you and
calling your workit Pudo science and
that at a certain point early on in your
journey you would write with the critics
in mind I've actually done that in my
work too where I can hear what people
are going to say and then so my
creativity starts leaning towards those
people and then I love that you wrote at
a certain point you were done with that
I I wanted to know if you could talk us
through that Evolution and thinking I
think if you really want to be a leader
you should study great leaders and I
think all great leaders in history are
un were
uncompromising I just don't care if they
did it for a good effect or a bad effect
they just were uncompromising to their
vision and and when you're young and you
write your first book and you're writing
that book and you're you're detailed and
specific about making sure you cross all
your tees and that all your eyes and
your references are all in place and you
want to go a little further for that
person who's in the back of the room or
that person who's the critic that's
going to judge your work and I think
it's a healthy place to start because it
creates it's a little
rigger and then I just had a lot of
people that hated me and I don't know
what I ever did to
them and and and and I had to really sit
down with myself and say do you think
that person's ever going to like you Joe
despenza they're never going to like you
anyway so forget them there's plenty of
people that do want to hear you and then
when I took my attention off those
people I started getting happier and
then when we started seeing the results
that were taking place I could care less
what they said about me I could care
less the events follow-ups were actually
created by our community because their
real passion and interest was to get
together again with the community and so
we created these events follow-ups for
people to come dressed as their future
selves and then we would Advance the
understanding of the retreat that they
had been part of that
year and go a little further to apply
the formula a little bit further to see
what what's possible by doing it and and
I want people to come that really want
to be
there I want people to come that really
have been practicing something that
they're after the mystical they're after
healing whatever it
[Music]
is and then we can go a little further
down that rabbit hole and see what's
possible and so they're designed for
advanced students that want to deepen
their understanding and a lot of times I
try out a lot of new things just to see
if it's possible we know according to
the epigenetic model that the
environment signals the gene without a
doubt and in products of an experience
in the environment is an emotion so by
people sustaining elevated heart-c
centered emotions and getting really
good at doing it with their eyes open
they're signaling genes ahead of their
environment and genes make proteins and
proteins are responsible for the
structure and function of the body and
the expression of proteins is the
expression of life now when the person
understands if I live by this emotional
state every single day and my body is so
objective that it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience that's creating this emotion
yes and the emotion that I'm fabricating
by thought alone and they assign meaning
to the ACT I'm doing this because I want
to Signal new genes the moment they
assign meaning to the ACT they switch on
their prefrontal cortex and they get
greater value from the act that means
then they start noticing that their pain
levels start to diminish that their
range of motion starts to improve that
they're sleeping better uh that they
feel more calm and more present the
moment they notice those changes that
are happening now their meditation
becomes even more thoughtful even more
powerful because now they're noticing
the effects of them themselves at cause
they're not waiting forther healing to
feel wholeness and gratitude they
understand that feeling wholeness and
gratitude is actually creating their
healing which is a Quantum principle
which in the quantum you got to feel it
first to exper before you experience it
so but but if you don't know that then
you're waiting for your outer something
in your outer World to Change or waiting
for something to change in your biology
in order for you to feel gratitude or
feel whole and that's just the old model
of of cause and effect the the quantum
model is about causing an effect the
challenge is that there's a period of
going from the old self to the new self
that is that unnown place where you're
always looking and when the moment
you're looking you're separate from it
so it takes training it takes practice
and we know that if a person immerses
themselves in a retreat for 3 days or 7
days and we give them the the knowledge
and we use science as that model when we
combine quantum physics with
neuroscience and neuroendocrinology and
psychon neuroimmunology and uh
epigenetics we we in electromagnetism we
give them that knowledge and information
and if knowledge is power knowledge
about yourself is self-empowerment so
and the mind can rest and and the mind
can actually understand what it's doing
and why it's doing and when you
understand the what and the why the how
gets easier and doesn't matter how sick
you are doesn't matter how old you are
how in shape you are how out of shape
you are if you ever meditated before
we've got the data to show that none of
those things actually matter it's just
really understanding the process and
giving people numerous opportuni ities
to overcome themselves meditation the
actual translation of the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors you
have to become aware of your emotions
that keep you anchored to the past and
if you can become so conscious of the
one unconscious states of mind and body
that they would never slip by your
conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision plan your behaviors
review them in your mind now if you keep
doing that over and over again nerve
cells that fire together wire together
you begin to become familiar with a new
state of mind at the same time if you
can emotionally cultivate your
inspiration your joy Your Enthusiasm
ahead of the experience by repeating
that over and over again cultivating
that state it's going to begin become
familiar to you so then the process of
change then requires unlearning and
relearning breaking the habit of the old
self Reinventing a new self pruning
synaptic connections as we say in
neuroscience and sprouting new
connections
process it's going to feel a little bit
unfamiliar uncomfortable and if you can
relax into that instead of going back to
the past continuously invest in your
future sooner or later it'll begin to
become easier and easier and easier and
all of a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't person in the world that's
excluded from this equation I see your
passion you're passionate about what
you're doing your your passion in your
work is really tangible and um do you
see it as a mission uh are you in a
mission how do you see it unfolding in
the future and um what does the future
of this Mission uh look like in respect
of your um growing worldwide Community
um your scientific research I know it's
a lot and the potential for personal
transformation for me I I do have a
passion and I do have a mission and that
I believe that in order to transform a
culture to transform a community to uh
transform the world you have to start
with the individual and so my passion
and my interest is human change human
potential uh human transformation and um
uh for me that mission is I believe that
if we can teach
people uh how to heal themselves uh uh
how to heal others if we can teach them
a new way of life uh in terms of what is
possible uh I think if we can uh produce
outcomes uh in seeing people that that
demonstrate that in some way uh I think
it does a change Consciousness so I'm
very Mission driven and I think that the
highest form of motivation is a
mission-driven motivation when you when
you have a vision that's bigger than you
and so um I'm happy to say that that's
what gets me up in the morning that's
what gets my team up in the morning uh
that when we uh celebrate someone's uh
personal change or personal
transformation personal healing um I
think that inspires us to to want to do
more of it so
um that type of personal conviction that
comes with that mission means that every
day you have to get your behaviors to
match that Vision or that mission that
intention um I think it's important to
navigate with a sense of Ethics a sense
of morality uh and and and to show
people um that you can demonstrate this
work by being examples so how do I see
it affecting our growing Community
uh I think there has to be an emergent
Consciousness on the planet that it
shows people that there's another way of
living and so I'm so proud of our
community because we're doers we do the
work uh we practice uh being creators of
our lives and I think it's important to
show people uh in the world what love
does uh that if we want forgiveness in
the world we have to show people what
forgiveness looks like if we want to
heal the world um then we have to heal
ourselves uh if we want peace in the
world we have to show the world what
peace looks like we have to demonstrate
that uh and I think because an emerging
Consciousness comes out of that uh
Consciousness is an awareness and the
awareness that there's another way to
live uh and another way to thrive I
think um gives people permission to to
to believe that it's possible so we have
this emergent Community this this
emergent Consciousness that really is
about uh being at cause in their life
instead of being at effect and I think
that each
individual uh in our community is a
representation of the whole so if you're
working on overcoming your fear or your
pain or your past or trauma that's
happened to you if you're working on
overcoming a health
condition um and I'm working on my own
thing and if we're truly truly on that
that path uh I what what comes out of
that is human goodness for all my
listeners what's step one so we're not
going to take them from very egocentric
and uh physically oriented to the end
mystical Journey overnight but what's
step one that you suggest and recommend
that everyone gets on tomorrow when they
wake up look I mean it's really simple I
don't have a problem with you uh putting
your attention on your body I think you
should I think you should really take
care of your temple and make sure that
you treat it really well but there's a
time when you you have to get Beyond it
and if you can't Beyond get Beyond it
then um that that's your identity so so
I I think that people come to this work
for many different reasons some people
come for health conditions or diseases
people come because they want a new life
people come because they want answers
but I don't really care what a person
comes for because ultimately when they
start connecting their values change and
they start feeling differently and they
change and and um they still have a
great body and they still have a a
healthy body but in addition to that
they have a healthy mind and and um so
um I think really a great start for
people is to wake up in the morning and
ask themselves the simple question what
is the greatest ideal of myself that I
can be today what is the greatest
expression of myself and really sit down
and decide who they want to be when they
open their eyes and just the act of
closing your eyes and thinking about it
and making choices differently than you
typically do and and rehearsing them
them and and actually follow through and
doing them is going to lead you to A
Whole New Life over time so it's not
that mystical because the mystical is
the side effect it's a phenomenon of
this work the the the real thing is to
to to have a a more profoundly enriched
life where you're in it and you love it
and you want more of it that's uh that's
what I want for everybody and for some
people it may be the mystical for some
people it may be a million dollars or
$10 million I don't care I just want
them to create it just whatever you want
just get busy creating it and prove to
yourself really how powerful you are and
um we got a lot of people doing it and
inade a brain wave patterns you tend to
pay more attention to your outer world
that's healthy so then when you're
aroused though by the hormones of stress
now you move into that high beta brain
wave pattern and now you're overly
Analytical in fact you're trying to
figure things out and when you're when
you're aroused by those stress stress
hormones and the emotions of those
hormones are record of the past our
research shows that when you're
analyzing some problem some condition
something about yourself within that
emotion you're making your brain worse
because you're driving it further into
higher beta brain wave patterns because
as you think about the problem you start
producing more of the chemistry and then
you start analyzing and all of a sudden
you get caught in this Loop how many
people understand and people stay
stuck for many many many years in that
high beta brain wave pattern and now
they're riant on something outside of
them to change that state whether it's a
drug a drink whatever it is a computer
game something to help them to to to uh
change their internal State people think
that they want certain things because
they're experiencing
lack and and so they have to go about
becoming the very person so then if we
reframe it and you say oh I really want
to be wealthy I want all my needs met
and I'll say really why you want to be
wealthy and they'll say cuz I want
freedom I'd say okay let's focus on
freedom so now the person understands
the sponsoring thought or the emotion
why would you wait for your wealth to
feel free that's the Newtonian model of
reality of cause and effect waiting for
someone or something out there to take
away this emptiness or lack H and what
if I'm feeling this emotion this emotion
is influencing certain thoughts and how
I think and feel creates my life if I'm
living in lack I'm not going to create
anything
new but if I say to you hey when you
become that
person once you become it then your your
reality is going to reorganize itself
instead of living by cause and effect
let's teach you how to cause and effect
so then the person then is no longer
interested in getting something in their
environment when they realize it's about
who they become and all of a sudden now
the emphasis or the interest is in
becoming that person and we have a week
with those people and I want them to
walk as it sit as it stand as it lay
down as it I want them to get in the
habit of walking from their room to the
ballroom it's become the new habit
that's why when we do our work you're
we're doing sitting meditations we're
doing standing and walking meditations
we're doing lying down meditations I
want it to become a new habit I want
them to become that person one of my
biggest problems is that I tend to react
quickly to negative situations how how
can I coup with anger do you have any
suggestions or
advice yeah I'll tell you the first
thing it's not that you react we all
react the question is how long are you
going to react that's the question
so we found out that when people react
emotionally with anger uh with
antagonism uh there's an arousal that
takes place because you're turning on
the sympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous system is a
primitive system saying Alex whatever
that whatever that is is a threat to you
and if there's a threat a good way to
deal with a threat is to get aggressive
it's primitive it's animal it's very
animal some people will say oh my
God there's my ex and instead of getting
angry they run they they they they flee
they're in fear they're like the fear is
I'm better just getting away so they
they the fear causes them to run uh uh
so uh when people feel fear when they
feel anger when they feel pain those are
the primary stimulators that switch on
that sympathetic nervous system and they
used to say that it's
automatic like it's automatic it happens
automatically that's part of the
autonomic nervous system and you really
don't have any control of it turns out
that's abs absolutely not the truth so
first
thing is learning how to shorten your
response to the emotional reaction so if
you have an event that happens to your
life in in your life and I say Alex why
are you so mad today and you say oh it's
because of this situation and this
person and this happened this way and I
would say oh my gosh are do you mean
that that person or that circumstance is
is
controlling the way you feel and the way
you think now anything that's
controlling the way we feel and the way
we think makes us
victims whatever that is now that's okay
but if you keep that emotional reaction
going on for hours or days and I say to
you Alex it's 5 days what's up and you
say to me I'm I'm upset from something
that happened to me 5 days ago go I'd
say you have a mood you're in a mood now
some
people keep that same emotional reaction
going on for weeks or months and then I
would say well Alex has a angry
temperament it becomes a temperament if
we keep it going for now this is true
people keep this going for years on end
if it goes on for years now it's a
personality trait so here's the weird
part about it you ask that person who's
been angry for years why they're
angry and they'll recall an event from
10 years ago or a series of events from
10 years ago and childhood yeah and the
research on the memory says that 50% of
that story isn't even the truth they
they can't even remember the truth they
embellish the story and make it sound
worse than it really was to excuse
themselves from changing now what we
tell people
is forget the event doesn't matter the
details of the event doesn't what
matters is learning how to overcome the
emotion so when you're sitting in a
meditation and all of a sudden out of
nowhere your body starts getting aroused
and it starts getting frustrated and it
starts getting angry and people say I'm
doing my meditation wrong you know what
I say to them no no no no you're doing
it right because that has to come up so
then so when the anger and the
frustration comes up and a person's in a
meditation they have one of two choices
to quit which is what they've always
done but if you're sitting with, 1500
people and no one else is quitting
you're not going to quit and if I teach
you how to lower the volume to that
emotion and I teach you a way to change
that I want to show you what it looks
like when you learn something new you
have a 100 billion neurons in your
brain 100 billion
neurons the number of connections you
have in one neuron is between 10,000 and
40,000 connections if you took 100 thou
100 billion sheets of paper and you
stack them on top of each other it would
be
5,000 Miles High that's the distance
from Los Angeles to London if you took a
scoop of gray matter the size of a grain
of sand you would have 100,000 neurons
in it with over a billion connections
now I'll stop right after this slide
learning is making new synaptic
connections every time you learn
something new this is what's happening
in your brain
Geniuses if you learned one bit of
information today your brain did
this boom that's
learning physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment every time you learn
something in your brain there's a
physical change that takes place and
learning is making new connections are
you with
me this is how fast it happens
too that's learning if you learn
anything this week you've made a
footprint if learning is making new
synaptic connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts over and over again you're
going to wire them in your brain so then
if learning is making new synaptic
connections then remembering is
maintaining them and all of a sudden
they develop a long-term relationship
and just like any relationship the more
you communicate the more they connect
and neurons are exactly the same
way now as you begin to learn
information
neurons tend to assemble themselves into
networks or what's called neural
networks and neural networks are just
gangs of neurons that have fired and
wired together to form a community of
neurosynaptic connections that's related
to a thought a skill a habit a behavior
a
concept and neural networks are
automatic programs you have a neural
network to brush your teeth to put on
makeup to speak a language to walk all
of a sudden those neurons then form a
hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic would you say it's smart to
focus on one goal I mean if you're sick
obviously it's it's smart to focus on on
getting healthy but if you have a
regular life and you say you know I
would like to have the classical stuff
more money uh more wealth more love more
joy
would you say in those meditations it's
smart to focus on different goals or
should it rather be the Big Goal like a
big Vision I have for my life that all
the steps on the way are just marks I
will pass at one point well let's answer
that on two levels too because people
come to our workshops for all different
reasons some people come because they're
sick some people come because they want
more money some people want more a new
job a new opportunity a new career a new
relationship some people want the
mystical that people come for all kinds
of reasons to me I don't care what I
care about is that they latch on to a
vision and they learn how to create
whatever drives them to that elegant
moment where they're so present and so
passionate about what they want and they
have a clear intention a Clear Vision a
coherent brain and they have an elevated
emotion combined with it that they
create hard coherence and now they're
broadcasting a whole new energy into the
field and whatever we broadcast into the
field is our experiment with Destiny so
I want
people to know the how because we have
plenty of people that have made millions
and millions of dollars that were living
in the backseat of their car or filed
bankruptcy we have plenty of people that
were stage four cancer serious health
conditions that are healed but
really people think they come for those
reasons but we come for wholeness that's
why we come that when we feel so whole
and so happy with ourselves so connected
to something greater if you feel
wholeness it's impossible for you to
want how can you want when you're whole
when you're whole you feel like you have
everything so I want people to reach
that point where they feel so whole uh
that they no longer want and that's when
the magic happens teaching them that uh
allows them to understand that when they
come back to their senses they open
their eyes they're not
looking for the experience they feel
like it's already happened and if you
feel like it's already happened why
would you be looking for it then if your
body is conditioned emotionally into
that
future um you're not separate from the
energy of your future you're connected
from it to it but the moment you get in
traffic and you start getting angry you
get on the line at the bank and you
start getting impatient or you're
sitting in a staff meeting you start
judging a
coworker you just disconnected from the
energy of the future and now you're back
to the energy of your past and you've
done nothing
wrong you just lost your connection to
the Future now now the importance of
that
is to notice that you're disconnected
and if you say to me well that person
made me feel this way and think this way
and say oh my gosh you're back to the
unconscious program of being a victim in
your life the victim is saying that
someone or something is controlling how
I think and feel but a person who's
producing outcomes in their life all of
a sudden they say wow the way I'm
thinking and feeling is creating
outcomes in my life now I'm a Creator in
my life and now I believe less that I'm
a victim of my
life for 10 more amazing rules from
Bruce Lipton check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there your life is a print out of your
programs you just look at your life and
recognize simple fact the things that
you like that come into your life they
come in because you have a program to
acknowledge those things but the things
you wish